cats are running the world  because they they took over the first of  all so first they while not giving a  [ __ ] about humans clearly would ever  with with every ounce of their being  they've somehow got just millions and  millions of humans to to to to take them  home and feed them and then not only the  physical space that they take over they  took over the digital space they  dominate the internet in terms of  cuteness in terms of immutability  and so they're they're like they got  themselves literally inside the memes  they become viral and spread on the  internet  and they're the ones that are probably  controlling humans that's my theory  another that's a follow-up paper after  the frog kissing